suite aux émeutes dans les Yvelines fin
juin qui sont survenus après la mort de
Naël lors d'un contrôle policier à
Nanterre l'État la Région Île-de-France
ainsi que les assurances ont mis en
place plusieurs mesures de soutien au
commerce dégradés les voici
pour les entreprises en difficulté
l'état reporte les charges sociales et
fiscales à titre exceptionnel il peut
également décider d'annuler totalement
toutes les charges vous pouvez demander
un délai de paiement sur votre espace
personnel sur le site de l'URSSAF en
plus des charges vous pouvez aussi
demander une modulation à la baisse du
taux d'impôt sur le revenu pour être
aidé dans ses démarches n'hésitez pas à
contacter une conseillère départementale
et pour rappel la ministre délégué au
Commerce Olivia Grégoire a annoncé que
les soldes seront repoussés d'une
semaine elle se tiendront donc jusqu'au
1er août
un fond d'urgence de 2 millions d'euros
a été déployé par la Région
Île-de-France pour tous les commerces
qui ont été victimes de vandalisme
c'était de s'adresse aux entreprises de
moins de 51 salariés et interviendra
après les assurances afin d'agir sur le
reste à charge pour faire la demande
rendez-vous sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran
et plusieurs garanties dans vos contrats
d'assurance peuvent aussi vous venir en
aide par exemple une garantie émeute et
mouvement populaire est prévu dans la
quasi-totalité des contrats tous les
dommages matériels sont à leur pris en
charge la garantie perte d'exploitation
vous permet également d'être indemnisé
au niveau des pertes d'argent liées à la
fermeture de votre magasin pour être
indemnisé vous devez d'abord effectuer
un dépôt de plainte sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran vous
avez jusqu'à 30 jours après le sinistre
contre 5 habituellement pour déclarer un
dommage ne tardez pas trop